in life and in death
we give glory
uh hello you shouldn't be out here it's
not safe
what the hell hey can you hear me
it's you the child's father
child hey wait do you mean rose is she
here
rose rose yes
she is in great danger since mother
miranda brought her to the village we
have fallen into
darkness what are you talking about the
monsters
the castle bell herald's danger
they're coming no
wait where's rose who's mother miranda
the bell tolls for us all they're
coming again
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh
yes
i guess this leads to the castle
uh
uh
[Music]
close the door please
hey what are you doing here
stay back please don't hurt us
whoa it's okay i'm not gonna hurt you
i'm just glad to see normal people at
last have you seen any other survivors
no they're all in louise's house
and she's not answering in the gate is
locked quiet girl
he's an outsider
oh
[ __ ] we're setting ducks in here can
your old man walk
no one of the monsters cut him
he's lost a lot of blood we have to get
into louise's house
quiet there must be a way inside
stay here be quiet and don't move until
i get those gates open
[Music]
huh
uh
come on it's clear hurry hurry
took your damn time oh you're welcome
he's not used to relying on other people
i'm sorry
we'll be safe in here won't we safer
here than out there that's for sure
hey do you know anything about what's
going on here
it doesn't make any sense mother miranda
has always protected us
nobody's answer
father
[Music]
we have to get inside
just hold on a bit longer papa
hello anybody home
maybe a familiar voice louisa
open up it's me elena
stop shouting you'll draw the monsters
calm down who's this a friend stay back
oh father for god's sake julian let us
in
no they'll smell the blood you'll
endanger us all my father will die out
here
that's not my problem what's going on
these people want to let a dying man
into our home come now these people
are our friends go on go inside come now
this way you're not from this village
uh no i'm ethan
eulen go make yourself useful and check
the grounds
i said go
well if elena trusts you
then so do i come inside ethan
wait here i'll check on the others
so
this way
come inside the others are waiting
what the [ __ ] is this outsiders you're
gonna get us all killed
anton he helped leonardo and elena we
were doing fine by ourselves
please ethan take a seat
is this all that's left from your entire
village
all that's left all that's left
there is no one left a worthless
invalid a stupid
wailing [ __ ] and you've
you drag a bloody man and an outsider in
here like it's nothing
and expect to be all safe there is no
safe every sorry bastard out there has
been ripped in half
but tomorrow
tomorrow we'll all be dead
just like her damn husband put a socket
in roxanna that's enough
this house has protected my family for
generations
and drunk or not you are all welcome
and safe in here whatever
can someone please tell me what the hell
is going on here we don't know
one day we were a quiet devout village
and the next
the monsters came and attacked us
and they they kept coming wait louise
where is your husband did they
no no he he is out there
somewhere he he went to get help
yes yes that's that's it he he went to
fetch help
let us pray for him
for all of us good idea
come gather
great ones hear our voice
together as one
[Music]
as the midnight moon rises on black
wings
so we make our sacrifice
[Music]
now the tea should be ready come help me
elena please
that prayer i've heard it before there
was an old woman near the graveyard
give me
a that as crazy as a bag of rats there
is wisdom
in her devotion though and i hope it
protected her
as it shall protect us
[Applause]
what are you doing leonardo what's wrong
are you okay
we have to go
i said no
oh my god i'm so sorry father
hey hey that wasn't your father anymore
you did the right thing
elena elena no there's nothing you can
do
this entire place is collapsing
you couldn't save him he was already
gone
leave me alone no we're getting out of
here
together
i gotta get out of here
[Music]
uh
damn the fire's moving fast
what are you thinking step back we can
bust out with this
ugh
ethan are you all right i'm fine
let me back up again the fire there
isn't any time
grab on hurry
let's move don't worry
and try not to breathe in the smoke i
know
thank you ethan you're kind
i hope your family is safe
come on it'll hold
there that's our way out thank god
but what then the village is still full
of monsters
we can't fight them there's too many hey
hey don't talk like that we'll find a
safe house to put you in until i can
find my daughter
my hunch is she's in that old castle no
that place is full of nothing but blood
and death
and i don't want to be alone while
you're father
no that's not him not anymore
he said my name father wait it's not
safe
stay there
come on give me your hand
ethan go save your daughter
elena don't give up
reach for me
god damn it
why is everyone dying on me
this is just too much
i just don't get it
this place is going mad
why the [ __ ] is this happening again
ah [ __ ]
[Music]
oh who's
[Laughter]
who was what was that
death yes
death has visited them all
[Music]
[Laughter]
hahahahahahaha
nothing but blood and death huh
up
uh
uh
ah
[Music]
so
uh
where have they taken rose
oh we meet again
duke why are you here where there's
coin to be made
and have you found your daughter no
if she is truly here the lady of the
castle would have kept little rose in
her private chambers
would she not tell me trusk the very
same
why don't you take a look maybe you'll
get lucky
and speaking of looking care to make a
purchase
if it's just looking window shop away
you'll be slaughtering things in droves
do you have enough firepower i can now
offer an expanded weapon modification
service
do let me know if you find anything else
of value
uh
uh
uh
uh
[Music]
huh
i haven't cut open a man in a while
let me string you up slice your jugular
and just watch take an alive dead witch
would you prefer
you will look wonderful mounted in our
hall
uh
[Music]
foreign uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
i can't believe cassandra called all
this mess
a healthy man's blood
[Music]
i can't wait
squeeze the blood out when they're alive
and it's that
much
one
you